of cars here no I think it got it like
the car vanities go up to like nine
seaters yeah until you have to like
Minnie Mouse yeah minibus yeah
um what about you what what kind of wife
were you and what type of wife would you
like to be
um
so I was a
confused wife
um
the masculine wife a wife who
so for context I'm the eldest so I add
this I just wanna say something before
I want to hear you about your day-to-day
because I know that you're going to be
struggling with what you're going to say
about your husband that's why I can see
you're picking and choosing so I just
wanted to let you flow with yeah what
your day-to-day life was like then and
what your date and what you'd like it to
be like because I know that you're gonna
respect things so I'd rather that you
just stick rather than put yourself in
it I'd rather you just say like what did
you do like get up in the morning
because you said you were doing
everything so this is your day-to-day as
as you were yeah so pre-baby I mean I
think we had
uh six months of marriage before I got
pregnant
and then obviously nine months so you
know just over a year of just us and it
was okay wake up in the morning no
before do you wake up I mean I've always
worked so ever since I turned 16 you get
your ni number I've always worked and
I've studied and then I went into my
career so it was always a wake up at six
A.M
um work out
um shower go to work come back and you
know the usual single life you put your
feet up you eat and then do it all again
I mean but when you got married before
you had the baby yeah what did you do
then same because we were working
different so he was doing shift work
obviously both yeah so he was doing
shift work and I was the corporate nine
to five so there's days where I'm going
to work in the morning and he's not
there or I'll come home and he's not
there
um he was cooking stuff yeah I was
cooking but that's what I mean you
didn't say anything you just made it
says I got up but I've done my stuff and
I went to an open I come home yeah I was
thinking at what time did you wake up
and start cooking for your husband
because this sounds like you know I
would have Separate Lives I would come
home from work and on the weekends I
would meal prep so you know us somalis
we like to have like our you know um our
big lambs and chickens and stuff so I'd
cook that on the weekend freeze it in
like little pouches so I know Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday yeah I
like what we're having
and so then all I've got to do is the
rice and the pasta or whatever it is
um and he would always come home and
there's always food even if I'll go to
sleep and he's finished at 11 or
whatever I've got his play everything
done microwave his cup drink next to it
everything just set up for him so when
he comes home he can just eat shower and
come to bed
um there were days where we would spend
time together so we'd end up coming home
at the same time and I'd we would both
make our duty to spend time together
then and you know cook together sit down
and eat because you know that you we're
still in our honeymoon period you know
we're still getting we're happy anyway
baby comes
um
not long after kovid came so I still
kept up with those duties and I
essentially was a stay-at-home mum for a
year for maternity leave so what that
would look like is
um whenever he's getting up to go to
work I'll make sure I have food ready
for him so his breakfast is ready
um at the time you know I've got a
three-month-old six month old however
older she was at the time but I'd always
make sure that he left with his stomach
full and would come home and his stomach
is full
um
we'd spend time together as a family
when he comes home from work and then do
it all again tomorrow so and I really
enjoyed that part and I actually got to
be you know more feminine I wasn't as
stressed
um you know because when you come home
from work you don't want to be was that
in the year that you enjoyed now the
coverage year did you enjoy it because
it obviously did go out you didn't go
out to work during the covid No No this
was pre-covered so 2019 so I had her in
December 2018. so from December 2018 to
December 2019 just before covert all
right I was a stay-at-home mum and I
loved it you know
um everything was covered it it you know
it was the ideal life for me you know I
would make sure that his clothes are
clean I'm ironing his clothes for him
like I'm trying to keep him
as the man like when he comes home from
work he's kind of you know
if I see that he's stressed out I want
to give him some of that some of my
feminine energy because I had a lot to
give at the time
um and try and make his day a little bit
better as much as I could
um without you how you've done that I'm
just asking because sometimes men just
want to come on just be left alone when
they're feeling amazing that's it that's
it and women tend to go
so I would gauge that like I'd say like
if he wanted cuddles or you know
obviously I'll see him sitting on the
sofa I'd go and sit on the sofa next to
him and if he wants a cuddle like he
like that's what that's what the leading
part of the men that we don't really
talk about so he'd come over to me and
lean over to me and I know that's my cue
you know I'd go over to him but if he
sits still and he doesn't want me to I
know he's had a really bad time at work
and me trying to cuddle up on him and
all that he's just like men are built
differently from us they don't want that
so I I would just leave him to it you
know I'd let him have his freedom and
let him have his space do do what you've
got to do
um would you have given at work to stay
at home and be a housewife if my bills
and everything was paid yeah happily
because I really liked it I really did
you know I spent time with my baby I got
to see her first steps I got to hear her
first if I was at work and like you know
in America I think you guys go back to
work a lot sooner than that I would have
missed all of that and you don't know
what's happening with your child like
you said you know you want your kid to
go to Nursery when they can form
sentences I wish I had that because I
was really anxious she was she was what
uh well covert hit so she was still at
home with me but I think she was really
two years old when she went to nursery
for some kids that's old you know that I
know but
for me so
um would you have gone down in lifestyle
in order to attain that
so maybe I can move to I don't know a
house or an apartment half the size yeah
yeah yeah because we lived in a really
small place and then when I got pregnant
we moved to a bigger place so if it
meant that I could still stay at home
and you know would you have stayed in
the smaller place yeah yeah okay no
problem at all I mean me talking about
earlier you know having maids and all
that's yeah for me that's a dream you
know and
um that's what my my parents have and
the kind of life that I came from but
it's not the life that I had with him
because I think I was kind of
not only battling with age but also
thinking you know you know Muslim girls
we get married young and how old were
you when you got married 28 wow so
that's you know that's hard for a man no
because I mean like you've been in the
career since you're 16. that's like 12
years of doing what you like and working
your own yeah you know what I mean yeah
and then to come in
wow yeah so that you know the medals
used to there was there was a lot that I
had to change and I think that's what um
this point in that it's a career woman
you see career woman a career woman as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible